hey guys I'm gonna attempt to be serious
today so bear with me as an enduro very
often and haven't really got much
practice I recently just hear 8000
subscribers and it's just kind of hit me
what's you know happens to be on YouTube
um it's just it's just insane I can't
quite even they get to grips with it
I'm just so humbled that so many people
like me to be honest with you I've
always been a shy quiet person this
happening to me on YouTube has given me
the confidence to be myself more you
know open out a little bit I wouldn't
have been able to get that without the
help of it's all very emotional as it is
yes so yeah 8,000 and I'm amazed and so
thankful I mean I can't thank you enough
really really can I'm never gonna be
able to thank you enough your other
subscribers you're the guys who think
I'm funny
thinking hearts think what a cute accent
or whatever whatever the reason you like
me I don't mind just the fact that you
like me at all is just so like I said
humbling and yeah I've made good friends
here on YouTube I don't think I would
and it's just amazing just so I don't
know thank you thank you thank you thank
you
I don't know I really got as you can see
I'm not very good as being serious I'm
Way well I guess I'll try and finish off
them thank you very much and I'll see
you all soon thanks for watching